[Music]
we're four episodes in and you still
can't get it right disney it's miss
marvel jeez first time to pakistan stop
normalizing [ __ ] strangers that
insist on talking to you on flights what
makes you say that you're gripping that
stuffed animal pretty tight this could
just as easily mean she's afraid of
flying missing her friends or that the
sloth is possessed by an ancient demon
from a forgotten realm that if unleashed
will devour the souls of the pure
through their eyeballs unless kamala
maintains a very specific grip around
its slothy abdomen you don't know
holding your heartwarming family reunion
in the middle of the [ __ ] arrival
gate at an incredibly busy airport take
your happiness where it isn't in the way
oopsie remember that time i was hanging
out of the car window and that guy had
to swerve out of the way and ended up
breaking both of his legs as he flew out
of control into that poor man's small
business
yeah good times
[Music]
no silly that's the fabled room of
expositioning could you tell by the
clearly vague instructions that led you
up your here are waiting for you no your
cousins have been rudely allowed to
stroll into your bedroom so they can
watch while you're sleeping you can
bring your flying teddy bear
oh i'm so sorry i'm late it's okay we
know it's because you're in a tv show
and therefore had no choice but to
arrive late because there's literally no
other recorded way to start a
conversation in a tv show or movie also
almost a quarter of this episode is
meeting family members man as wholesome
as that is i don't think it's the best
use of the show's time isn't there some
sort of threat to the fabric of reality
going on why is kamala acting like she
isn't being chased down by an evil group
of ancient gen it's yours if you tell me
the direction to the train station we've
seen in other scenes that kamala has a
cell phone that's still functioning in
pakistan so why doesn't she just pull up
at google maps instead of giving this
guy some money for confusing directions
one more left and then
right little little bit right okay this
despite kamala looking clearly confused
and borderline panicked works
where did kamala go graffiti artists can
go with any avenger for their rps and
they choose [ __ ] ant-man even scott
lang wouldn't choose ant-man at this
point chemo thinks that kamala is a
clandestine so he either deliberately
missed because he likes drama or he
somehow managed to miss an unprepared
enemy while they had their back turned
not sure what's worse those glasses you
try to run with that mask says the
individual wearing a mask do all my
family can have superpowers well how do
you know i'm not canadian kamala would
be deadpool at tv sins where'd you learn
to jump like that ninja turtles where'd
you learn yours huh donkey kong where'd
you learn to deliver those lame insults
the lame
insult store
who are you
what are you you're not a clandestine
you know about them how did you get it
from aisha answering so many questions
with so many other questions have these
kids never been told how to conversation
come with me if you want to live what
just kidding i've always wanted to say
that kimo here immediately goes from
trying to kill kamala because he thinks
she's a clandestine to joking around and
taking her to his secret base for no
apparent reason other than she seems
confused there's someone you need to
meet you'd better come take a look at
this person i need you to meet cliche
furnishing your secret hideout with a
glass ceiling that can be conveniently
broken into by your enemies not that
something like that would ever happen
wait what this was kamala all along for
hundreds of years that scarf has
protected the identity of warriors
willing to take on the mantle of the red
dagger assuming they aren't easily
identifiable by their ears eyes hair
fingerprints more dna of any sort it's
connected to a world but hid
behind the whale of noor that separates
our world from us i mean it's a very
pretty map but does it do anything else
like is it just pulled out for
expositional purposes how often are they
bringing in strangers and telling them
about the nor dimension that it requires
this fancy demo do you know what it says
it says what you seek is seeking you oh
what in case you confused it with the
department of disastrous colons i have
so many questions about what the [ __ ]
just happened here it looks like najman
has had a dagger in her hand all along
so how did the guards not see it and why
the she waited until now to use it i
swear marvel edits this stuff so quickly
i'm sure they're just hoping everyone
will be so suddenly befuddled that they
don't even question anything well that's
my secret marvel i'm always befuddled
everyone call her sloth
for this baby
oh sure whenever i start playing guitar
around the campfire everyone suddenly
has plans they forgot about and hair
they have to wash but when suave jones
here starts strumming away the entire
group is captivated
suave jones
me why is all this such a mess huh
and what are all these newspapers and
magazines kids
complaining to the person giving you a
free massage maybe it is time for you to
start considering coming to live with us
in america and maybe it's time for us to
consider a skip your humanity links you
to the matter of this world
it makes your abilities unique as long
as your definition of unique only
extends to big fists and stepping stones
am i a red dagger now premature
celebration
surprise surprise indeed how the hell
did they get here so fast it is at least
an 18-hour flight from new jersey to
karachi and kamala's only been here two
maybe three days so the clandestines
managed to break out of the dodc figure
out kamala was in pakistan fly there and
figure out where this top secret red
dagger base was and i demand to know who
gave them the script this completely
unflinching couple who pays zero
attention to the three people sprinting
past them as they enjoy their meal why
is she putting on the mask now why is
this mask
[Music]
i realize the clandestines would be
experienced and talented enough to pull
off a truck jacking but how is the
driver just landing to where he was
thrown as the truck is passing by that
would have required the ability to take
the driver out of the truck while i was
still moving and someone immediately in
the vicinity of the gas pedal and
steering wheel to keep it moving on
course and that's all the [ __ ]
come on man what do you want from her
it's not like she has some sort of
bracelet that can tap into a vast energy
source from a parallel dimension with
the ability to create matter at will
sheesh
conveniently broken down family is very
convenient or inconvenient i mean it's
obviously inconvenient for them but it's
a very convenient obstacle for look i'm
just saying this is some [ __ ]
manufactured attention get yourself to
safety i'll lead them off i'm amazed
even one of the clandestines chose to
follow him let alone their leader najma
they're just after the bracelet right
why do they give a [ __ ] about catching
waleed okay driving on the opposite side
of the road on stick you said opposite
side of the road instead of wrong side
of the road it's okay kamala we all make
mistakes honestly i don't even have the
mental fortitude to keep up with this
chase but i can confidently say that
this is some high grade bs that almost
everyone managed to end up on this
street at this exact time including and
especially this sudden deus ex
kamalakana
and let's just leave the truck behind
because it would have only gotten us to
wherever we needed to go faster being on
foot increases our chances of getting
caught so let's go that route pretty
sure that label should read convenient
instead of
caution have to help him it's too late
why is it with characters giving up so
quickly on their mentors kimo didn't
even have time to check a pulse that is
not his call to make i'm sure something
cool is happening right now so here are
10 extra sins for not showing it to us
and instead opting to offend my eyes
with a billion impossible to follow cuts
and whooshes thanks marvel again
cool are we gonna get some kind of
explosion of nor magic that rips a hole
in reality that will expose kamala to an
alternate dimension where everyone is
made of paint or rocks and wait are we
in the past
and i just succeeded if it weren't for
those meddling kids you're wearing a
shirt that says new
new
jersey
oh god family
there was no baby it was full of cats
you want to know the secret to surviving
air travel after you get where you're
going take off your shoes and your socks
then you walk around on the rug barefoot
and make fists with your toes
i didn't realize you were in here with
someone so you will be this armless
legless faceless thing won't you rolling
down the street like a turd
[Music]
i hate this
it is revolting in all the years and
everything i've heard about that bangle
there was no mention of an inscription
do you know what it says
hey beaver pull my finger we all go by
nicknames here right yeah what's yours
shark bait shark face
outstanding
now let's bite all the heads off and
follow up the corner